so Chinese citizens are now the fastest
growing migrant group crossing the
southern border with 24,000
apprehensions last fiscal year and a new
report says Tick Tock is to
blame we wondered how all of these
migrants knew about this particular
entryway into California the answer was
in their
hands oh you learned on Tik Tok the post
we found had stepbystep instructions for
hiring Smugglers and detailed directions
to that hole we visited so what is
causing the surge joining us now author
of confusious never said and the senior
Federalist at and contributor Helen
Raley and field reporter Julio Rosas
Julio uh let's go to you first when I
was at the border about five to six
years ago it was very rare to see a
Chinese National and when you saw them
they were Runners they weren't trying to
turn thems in what are you seeing now at
the
border well it's what we've been seeing
for the past few years now and the fact
that there's no fear that the fact that
we have uh border patrol essentially
trying to hide from illegal immigrants
and illegal immigrants are the ones
trying to find Border Patrol um that
that just shows how crazy things have
have become under this Administration
and it's the fact that you yeah exactly
it's not even Central or even South
Americans anymore it's people from all
over the world and people coming from uh
let's face it adversarial countries who
uh may want to do us harm and may want
to exploit us through this weak point
yeah so just to put it into persp
perspective in fiscal year 2021 450 22
2100 and then this Mass sub jump to over
24,02319
address The confusious Institute briefly
that's China uh the confusion Institute
are run by China's united front
Department which is a propaganda
division of the Communist party so the
confusious Institute are covered
operations to try to influence public
opinions in the west fortunately um many
universities over hundred of them has
been shut down since covid because many
people are waking up to it as for the
migrants issues um the unfortunately we
don't know who who they are uh I but I
think most of them based on I read and
what I heard most of them came to United
States they were really driven by first
of all the open invitation of our
lawlessness border um everybody else is
doing it face no consequences so they
are following those example and secondly
but most importantly they were driven by
China's uh political ongoing political
persecution and the deteriorating
economic situation uh for example China
just sentenced a banker and an
Australian writer to death uh this week
uh the banker was a commit the
Corruptions the writer was allegedly
writing articles criticizing of the
Chinese government while he was in
Australia so nobody feels safe in China
and then on the economic front there's a
high use unemployment rate uh the stock
markets deteriorating uh people saw
biggest drop of their salaries last year
as well as the property Market as
sluming and the pro propit market
especially hurting people's confidence
because over 70% of the Chinese people
have their personal wealth tied to
properties so all these factors combined
are driving people to come here Julio
what what are border patrol agents
telling you as well as Texas DPS are
they concerned about the folks coming
across um that are are Chinese
Nationals absolutely and it's just the
fact that this really hasn't happened
before at least in in these large
numbers and as I was saying before it's
not even we're not even talking about
people from Asia but you know we just
had that recent report where an
al-shabab terrorist uh didn't even avoid
border patrol he he turned himself in he
was processed and released and was in
the country for over a year before the
US government realized their mistakes so
um this is very concerning I've been
raising the warning for quite some time
about this you know Helen I only got 20
seconds real quickly to leave China do
you have to get approval from the
government I don't think so I think many
of them they basically fly to uh which
they do not need visa to go to Ecuador
and then from there they follow the Tik
Tok instructions past smuglers and make
that dangerous long and expensive trip
Helen thank you so much Julio excellent
reporter uh on the ground I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Ang airheart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis